hey what up guys my name is achernar and
welcome to something a little bit
different this is gonna be more or less
its log today we're gonna be talking a
bit about productivity and what it means
to be productive in programming and just
my thoughts on being productive in
general I need to go ahead and pack
because I'm going to San Francisco in
two days for GDC and instead of doing
that I'm gonna procrastinate and make a
video but first coffee
[Music]
so good it's not that I'm addicted to
coffee it's just that I pretty much need
it I'm damned I am addicted to coffee
alright sorry I thought I'd just make a
little bit of a video instead of
actually packing for San Francisco which
would be the probably the appropriate
thing for me to be doing right now
considering I am leaving very very soon
but I'm not a big fan of packing so here
we are making a video this is really
gonna be a bit of a chill video I didn't
plan this at all like I'm not saying
that I was I'm just procrastinating for
the sake of the video I actually this is
literally what's happening in my life
right now I'm I just literally thought
I'd just make a video because I like
recording on this camera it's nice and
small and it's a bit of a new camera for
me as well so it's really cool just
making videos anyway well we're gonna be
talking about today as I drink this
coffee and think about what I actually
should be taking with me on my trip is
the topic that I get asked a lot about
and that I am not sure I fully
understand myself because I struggle
with this as I'm sure a lot of people do
so this is just gonna be my thoughts as
with every video I make even the ones
that are technical and where I say this
and that specifically those videos are
all opinion based you have to realize
that even though I do my channel is kind
of a technical channel and I make a lot
of videos about how to do certain things
and in those videos I will be like this
is the only right way to do it that's
all an opinion people have different
opinions people work in different areas
there's no one answer for every problem
in the world so whenever I say things
like this this is just my experience my
opinion I'm 23 years old I'm not exactly
a 40 50 year old 60 year old elder or
whatever that had that knows everything
about life I have no idea what I'm doing
to be honest with you to be really real
with you is getting Dave anyway the
point is this is
my opinion take us with a grain of salt
I'm not a special person by any means
I'm just me so anyway I thought I'd talk
a little bit about motivation and
programming and productivity because
productivity and programming I'm gonna
try not bang my head in my hands on the
table cuz I know I chase the camera but
productivity in programming in software
engineering and game development in in a
lot of artistic areas and creative areas
as well is not exactly something that
you can measure right it's you can't
just I can't go to my manager and say I
wrote a hundred and fifty lines of code
today so it was about like an 8 out of
10 day or something like that that
doesn't exist because there is no real
metric to be able to measure
productivity you could also say hours
that I was actively involved in thinking
about the problem and coming up with a
solution to the problem maybe but even
then some days your brain will just be
on fire and you'll be coming up with all
these problems all this sorry all these
solutions to problems and you'll just be
you'll just be calculating things and in
an incredible space but other days
you'll just be sitting there and you'll
still be thinking about work it's not it
well it's not like you'll be
procrastinating and watching YouTube
videos like you might be now with this
one it's not like that it's more so the
fact that your brain is just not really
into it and so you won't be as as
product as productive on that specific
day as you might have been on other days
so that's not really a nice metric lines
of code definitely isn't because it
depends what you're writing if you get
tasked with rewriting something from
scratch and you have the basic idea of
the architecture there may be thousands
if not tens of thousands of lines of
code that you need to lay down and you
know exactly what you're doing so you
can wind up writing thousands of lines
of code per day I've done that before
maybe you're copying and pasting from
other kind of previous versions of the
same system so you're just pasting in
four thousand lines of code at a time
and slightly modifying an aura factoring
it but other days maybe one line of code
will take you two days or something
because it's very crucial line of code
and something was wrong it was very very
subtle and it was made
causing a bug on a specific CPU on some
kind of Android device or whatever it
might be incredible is incredibly narrow
and specific and it might take you a
really long time to write that single
line of code that is worth spending that
time so you can't measure productivity
on lines of code what else is there
task completion so like maybe you get
tasks with a bug like how do you how do
you determine house how simple local or
complex that bug is yeah it you can't
sometimes usually when a bug comes in
I'm speaking like from my experience at
work
usually when a bug comes in the first
step is identifying how that bug happens
there may already be reproduction steps
that you can actually do to kind of get
the bug to be reproduced every single
time and 100% of the time that you
perform those steps you will get that
bug that's really easy sometimes it'll
be something that happens very rarely
but what it does is catastrophic and so
you do need to fix it it might take you
a week to figure out how to actually
reproduce the problem so that your
debugger can catch it and then even then
that might be something that is
situational it might be like a race
condition between threads that you can't
replicate every time unless you figure
out the exact environment that you need
to actually make it happen software
engineering is such a complex field that
measuring productivity is pretty much
impossible so how do you become
productive how how can you maximize your
productivity I'm just gonna give a few
of my thoughts and what I think about
all that in a second
but I'm really interested to find out
what you guys think about being
productive and how you actually what
makes you productive because everyone is
different I mean that's for sure the
things that I find work for me might not
work for other people they might not
work for me a lot of the time as well
what makes you productive how do you
measure your productivity we all have
good days we all have bad days so how
can you actually ensure that you have
more good days than bad days okay so I
think personally the productivity is
very closely tied with motivation if
you're more motivated to do something
you're just gonna be more productive
right because you're it's not only that
you're enjoying what you're doing it's
more so that you have a strong desire to
actually do the tasks that you're
currently doing and that desire
I feel translates directly into your
brain just being more switched on and
being able to come up with things if you
hit a roadblock but you're motivated you
won't you won't think about it and be
like oh no I have to do this you'll kind
of be like okay no worries I got this
plan I got this plan I got this plan
let's just start executing them
straightaway you're in the zone right
you'll continue just working you're just
pumping out whatever solution to
whatever problem is even though I'm kind
of talking about programming right now
by the way this applies to everything
I'm not just a software engineer I'm a
musician I like taking photos I like
making videos I like plenty of other
things I'm really into art and all that
stuff there's more to me than just
programming so when I'm talking about
this I'm definitely talking more like
even though the emphasis is kind of in
the examples I'm giving are with
software engineering in general there's
applies to anything right whether it be
making a video for me because that's
something that I need motivation for us
well and that's something that obviously
is depending on how productive I am I
can't imagine how three videos in one
day sometimes sometimes I just can't
even make one because I'm just not into
it at all right but if you're motivated
to do something then you become more
productive if I come to work and
suddenly the thing that I'm working on
is I don't know a new real-time and
reflection system or something really
cool that I might be into this is just
an example then I'll want to come into
work earlier pretty much to just get on
with the task and to see how how I can
do it because
that's like all I can think about I'm in
the zone right now I'm motivated by this
task that I'm doing so I'll be more
likely to continue working on it and
spend more hours on it and even when I
get home I'll still be thinking about it
and coming out with different different
ways whereas if I'm doing something
really really boring at work let's think
about something maybe I'm just triaging
bugs for like some tool that no one uses
or whatever then that will that might
actually take me longer even though it's
nowhere near as complex because it's
more boring and being bored is
definitely something you want to avoid
so if motivation is tied in with
productivity then really what you should
be doing is finding ways to motivate
yourself that might be a topic for
another video but finding motivation is
key I really do believe that if you can
find ways to continually keep motivating
yourself to do things then you will be
more productive and that's gonna be
better for everyone right it's going to
be better for you it's going to be
better for people you're working with
it's going to make your life more fun
and I definitely believe that it will
probably make you happier and maybe even
make you a better person
if you're definitely too motivated on a
certain project that you're working on
that you're not socializing with anyone
and you refuse to see your family or
whatever because you're so busy that's
obviously very negative and that's bad
but in general you'll probably be the
less the less bored you are the happier
you are I feel and that's not to say
that being busy is good because if
you're super busy and you're too busy
that can definitely be bad and you don't
have time to be bored so you're not
bored but that doesn't necessarily mean
you're happy anyway this is turning into
like some kind of psychology
psychiatrist session I don't want it to
turn into that but those are kind of my
thoughts so finding motivation is the
key to productivity and since you can't
really measure productivity in software
engineering then you just have to find
ways to motivate yourself because that
will result in high productivity levels
even though you currently measure the
product
I mean you can what metrics would you
think you could use to measure
productivity because that is an
interesting thought I mean I I still
think it's something that isn't really
measurable and because of that if you
can find ways to keep yourself happy and
motivated then you will just be more
productive and even though opportunity
isn't something you can measure you can
definitely relatively measure it right
so I had a two out of ten day versus an
eight out of ten day you just know that
you were more productive that day
because you were happier you were less
tired you were more passionate about the
thing that you're actually working on
not necessarily a way to absolutely
measure productivity but it is relative
to your like yep what what I did
yesterday I was more productive today
than I was yesterday and finishing
certain products and more finishing
certain tasks is also not really a good
metric because it mmm really depends on
the complexity of the problem which
itself is hard to measure anyway those
are my thoughts I don't wanna make this
video too long or anything I really
should get packing but I just wanted to
share my thoughts with what I think
about being productive in this industry
and in every industry definitely let me
know what your thoughts are I'm really
excited to read some of your comments
and see maybe I am missing a piece in
the puzzle maybe there is something that
can make you more productive
I like being productive a lot because I
don't know being bored for me does kind
of I think make me a little bit more
depressed and just a bit more a bit less
happy than if I'm actually doing
something and going out there and
working I don't know maybe I'm just
addicted to work
but anyway oh this is getting I don't
even have time during my coffee this is
getting really deep I will see you guys
next time good bye oh and one more thing
before I get back to packing if you want
to follow my journey to San Francisco
and JDC and all of that definitely
follow me on Instagram I'll have a link
in description my name's just the turn
on Instagram I'll be posting tons of
stories with my entire adventure and all
that and and I've heard that coffee in
America is terrible I know that
Melbourne which is where I live is known
for having really really good coffee so
I probably can't expect that level of
coffee in San Francisco but surely there
are some good cafes please let me know
where I can get good coffee in San
Francisco otherwise I'm we're just gonna
just not gonna make it out I think
anyway see you guys later goodbye I love
you like a madman to but though my heart
is falling - I'm in love your body yeah
last night you in my room I'm not my bed
sheets smell like you every day
discovering something brand-new I'm in
love your body
oh I'm in love yoy yoy I'm in love with
you I'm in love with you body
everybody's covering something brand new
I'm in love with the shape of when we
can't even let the story like I really
need to go pack